Now it's time to evaluate our
models on the testing set.
So the first model we're
going to want to look at
is that smart baseline model
that basically just took
a look at the polling results
from the Rasmussen poll
and used those to
determine who was
predicted to win the election.
So it's very easy to
compute the outcome
for this simple baseline
on the testing set.
We're going to want to table
the testing set outcome
variable, Republican,
and we're going
to compare that against
the actual outcome
of the smart baseline,
which as you recall
would be the sign of the testing
set's Rasmussen variables.
And we can see that
for these results,
there are 18 times where
the smart baseline predicted
that the Democrat would
win and it's correct,
21 where it predicted
the Republican would win
and was correct, two times
when it was inconclusive,
and four times where
it predicted Republican
but the Democrat actually won.
So that's four mistakes and
two inconclusive results
on the testing set.
So this is going
to be what we're
going to compare our logistic
regression-based model against.
So we need to obtain final
testing set prediction
from our model.
So we selected mod2, which
was the two variable model.
So we'll say, TestPrediction
is equal to the predict
of that model that we selected.
Now, since we're actually
making testing set predictions,
we'll pass in newdata
= Test, and again,
since we want probabilities
to be returned,
we're going to pass
type="response".
And the moment of truth,
we're finally going to table
the test set Republican value
against the test prediction
being greater than or equal to
0.5, at least a 50% probability
of the Republican winning.
And we see that for this
particular case, in all but one
of the 45 observations in the
testing set, we're correct.
Now, we could have tried
changing this threshold
from 0.5 to other values and
computed out an ROC curve,
but that doesn't quite make
as much sense in this setting
where we're just trying
to accurately predict
the outcome of each state
and we don't care more
about one sort of error--
when we predicted Republican
and it was actually
Democrat-- than the other,
where we predicted Democrat
and it was actually Republican.
So in this particular
case, we feel OK just
using the cutoff of 0.5
to evaluate our model.
So let's take a look now
at the mistake we made
and see if we can
understand what's going on.
So to actually pull out
the mistake we made,
we can just take a
subset of the testing set
and limit it to when
we predicted true,
but actually the
Democrat won, which
is the case when
that one failed.
So this would be
when TestPrediction
is greater than or equal to 0.5,
and it was not a Republican.
So Republican was equal to zero.
So here is that
subset, which just
has one observation since
we made just one mistake.
So this was for the year
2012, the testing set year.
This was the state of Florida.
And looking through these
predictor variables,
we see why we made the mistake.
The Rasmussen poll gave the
Republican a two percentage
point lead, SurveyUSA
called a tie,
DiffCount said there
were six more polls that
predicted Republican
than Democrat,
and two thirds of
the polls predicted
the Republican was going to win.
But actually in this case,
the Republican didn't win.
Barack Obama won
the state of Florida
in 2012 over Mitt Romney.
So the models here
are not magic,
and given this sort of data,
it's pretty unsurprising
that our model actually
didn't get Florida
correct in this case
and made the mistake.
However, overall, it
seems to be outperforming
the smart baseline
that we selected,
and so we think that maybe
this would be a nice model
to use in the
election prediction.